what's up everyone I'm Anna Dua and I'm in Toronto
Ontario the heart of hockey ahead of the 2024 NHL
Allstar Weekend do you think we can find anyone
in this entire city that doesn't know what's
going on this weekend I mean it is hockey's
Capital right let's find out so do you know
what's happening in Toronto this weekend sure
is it's the allstar game the allstar week it's
the allstar game it is the allstar game there
you go the hockey the hockey here the like the
champion hockey something something Allstar yes
here we go allstar game yes yes yeah do you know
what's happening in Toronto this weekend no idea
what's going on nothing no idea no idea who guys
know what's happening in Toronto this weekend no
no happens once a year brings together all of the
League's best players NFL NHL Allstar Weekend oh
let's live do you guys have any guesses as to what
any of these skills might be I mean I would hope
skating um Cheo in the clock um and you know being
cute this year we have celebrity co- captains
for the all-star teams to famous Canadians who
are going to be part of the festivities and he
guesses as to who they are a few of them yeah
um will Arnette and famous Canadians Neil Young
younger female Canadian celebrity she's blowing
up on Tik Tok right now blank okay Neil Young
might have done it when Cujo was still in the
league I mean I'd like I'd like it to be Justin
Bieber to be honest it is Justin Bieber first
guest you're correct one big hockey fan famous
Canadian who's going to be there you ask to be
I don't know girl who is it you got to tell me
Justin beer the Beast what he's going to be here
the be is going to be there D let's get it how are
you excited for NHL Allstar Weekend yeah that's it
I'm